aux etats unis l'état de la louisiane
fête cette année le tricentenaire de la
fondation de la colonie française il
faut savoir que plus de 900000
descendants d'acadiens deux français
deux canadiens vivent dans cet état
phénomène récent de plus en plus
d'enfants veulent étudier le français
alors que leurs propres parents ne
parlent pas jacques garnier et didier
kaeslin se sont rendus dans une école
dans la banlieue ouest de lafayette en
louisiane
l'école de la prairie accueille chaque
jour plusieurs dizaines de petits
américains qui viennent d'y apprendre le
français
marianne chers amis que nous n d'origine
enseigne sans difficulté notre langue à
ses enfants qui sont parfaitement
bilingues
beaucoup de ces enfants des
grands-parents des arrêts temporaires
qui parlent français
les parents ici comprennent l français
et beaucoup commencent à le parler
l'apprennent à travers leurs enfants
lorsqu'ils ont réussi valeurs très très
mal le français
il a eu déjà une année de france un
matériel en dernier avec des profs qui
viennent du canada de la belgique de la
france a peu ça dépend il parle france
ils comprennent 10 quelques mots puis la
première année si la ouvrant ses pc là
où vraiment les enfants parlent fort des
phrases complètes
l'asthme est bien parlé avec qui tu
parles à la maison avec maman papa par
le français non qu'est ce qu'il veut
faire plus tard hongrie est un parent en
sang
la génération des parents de ces enfants
est la première génération qui ne parle
pas français comme certains le font la
plupart ont appris l'anglais en première
l'an
et il ya tout un espoir avec ses six
enfants lors four justement refaire le
point entre leurs grands-parents et et
ses petits américains n'auront pas comme
leurs grands parents
honte de l'héritage de laurent serre ils
sont plus de 80 milles à travers la
louisiane à apprendre le français
la découverte de notre langue les
passionne pour refermer s'y soustraire